Thank You mr. Pearson for being with us
thanks for the invitation yeah
what I found most interesting in your
book is the stuff you write about child
development and child upbringing and for
example you explain how overprotective
parents can damage their children you
say it's far better to render beings in
your care competent than to protect them
do you think that the parents today are
more protective of their children than
previous generations I would say that it
looks like that yes I think there are
complex reasons for that I don't think
that you can necessarily lay that at the
feet of the parents people are having
fewer children and they're having them
later in life and so I think both of
those things those are major demographic
shifts and I think that one of the
consequences of that is that children's
lives are much more organized than they
used to be which might have some
advantages but that also parents are
more likely to over protect their older
and more cautious and the children also
don't have as many siblings and of
course siblings were part of the child
raising process and and it's hard to be
over protected in some ways when you're
competing with a bunch of siblings so
it's complicated but I think that over
protection is a problem mm-hmm rule 11
is to not polit children when they are
skateboarding this is a recurring theme
in your book if we are overprotective
with our children we will create weak
individuals while you you demolish
people's resilience that way I mean life
is difficult and you cannot protect your
children what you can do is prepare them
and you can prepare them to be strong
and courageous and truthful and
resilient and reciprocal in their
interactions with other people and that
means you equip them for what life will
be which is at minimum a series of
difficult challenges and and often more
than that because of course people go
through very difficult times in their
lives and a resilient person is capable
of standing up to things in the face of
fear and moving forward voluntarily
convinced of their own competence and
ability to prevail
and so the primary your primary goal as
a parent apart from facilitating your
child's social desirability which is a
major obligation on your part is to
encourage your children and to and I
mean that literally to instill in them a
sense of courage in the face of the
difficulties of life and not to protect
them from that we don't even want to be
protected from those difficulties
because a major part of life and its
meaning is the the challenge that comes
with confronting difficulties so yeah
what do you want to say to those parents
that allow their eight or nine-year-old
sons to sleep in their bats at night
instead of sleeping in their own rooms
well I the first thing I would say about
that is you might want to ask why you
don't want privacy with your spouse you
know the last thing you want to do is
use your child as an excuse to not
interact properly with your wife or your
husband there's all sorts of reasons
that people allow their children to
interfere with their relationship and so
and by eight or nine a child is more
than capable of spending time on their
own and they need to do that anyways
because you don't want your child to be
either unable to spend time alone or
terrified of it you you also destroy to
some degree their while their ability to
cope on their own but also their
imagination by not requiring them to
rely on themselves for their own like
call for self calming and safe and also
for self amusement there's a rule when
you're dealing with people who might be
dependent and this includes and includes
the situation where you're dealing with
sick people or or elderly people and the
rule is do not do anything for anyone
that they can do for themselves because
you take away their competence by doing
that I want to ask you about the use of
physical force and children because you
think it is important to allow kids to
explore and harm themselves to gain
experience still you believe strict
parenting is important and you think
this justifiable to flick the index
finger on to certain types of
two-year-olds why is the use of force
justifiable and policy turns on the
context and it also depends on what you
mean by force there isn't a disciplinary
strata
that you can utilize that doesn't
involve something that's unpleasant
while you can use reward but that that's
a different there's different
circumstances underway and you should
use reward every time you can because
it's more effective but you often need
something that's instantaneous and that
gets the message across and a flick is a
very good technique because it's instant
it's harmless it gets the message across
you can use it publicly
it can't be misused you won't hurt the
child
you have to have an effective
disciplinary strategy for you since in
social situations for example yeah you
talk about the minimizing minute yeah
well the basic rules are quite
straightforward minimum number of rules
because otherwise the enforcement costs
accrue and you end up constraining
yourself and the child too much and then
minimal necessary force and you might
ask well what's minimal necessary force
and the answer to that is minimum
intervention necessary to bring the
behavior to a halt as rapidly and
harmlessly as possible and that has to
be negotiated with the child because
some children are much more difficult to
stop than others but isn't it possible
that the parent-child relationship can
be damaged if basic trust and safety is
lost so it's absolutely the case that
it's it will be damaged yes
but the application of judicious
disciplinary force doesn't damage the
relationship it actually strengthens it
and everyone knows this look if if you
have a relationship with your wife let's
say the relationship is partly based on
mutual respect not merely on mutual love
it's also based on mutual respect and
you everyone tests out their partner to
determine what their limits are and if
you're not subject to corrective action
on the part of your partner you will
have no respect for them your
relationship will just deteriorate very
rapidly so and it's very important to
understand that the limits that you
place on children are not something that
impede their child parent relationship
but actually further it substantially I
want to talk about gender equality now
yeah and chapter 11 you write about the
so called oppression of the patriarchy
and you write it loose
me like the so-called oppression of the
patriarchy was instead an imperfect
collective attempt by men and women
stretching over millennia to free each
other from privation disease and tragic
so the oppression of women happened
because it was practical no the the
oppression of men and women happened
because life is difficult and
treacherous and so we were subject and
still are to all sorts of terrible
burdens that are intrinsic to life
itself I mean one of the things that's
happened is because we're so technically
and materially wealthy right now we
don't understand what privations our
ancestors even a few generations ago
faced I mean it was very difficult for
women to function let's say as as
technical equals in the absence of
reliable control of menstruation that's
only been a reality for say seventy
years and the birth control pill as well
is it a major technology or revolution
you you mentioned technological
advancement yes so the hurdles have been
removed in part way but you talk about
the so-called oppression of the
patriarchy yes what women were oppressed
for centuries I mean well that's one way
of looking at it or the other way of
looking at it is that men and women were
oppressed for centuries I mean there are
certain burdens that women bore that men
didn't bear but the opposite is equally
true yeah men suffered dreadfully for
example in incredibly dangerous
occupations but is the fact that women
suffered more than the man I don't
believe that no one I don't think it is
a fact I think that most people suffered
by modern standards immeasurably and
that I don't buy the historical
narrative that the fundamental reality
of our history was that men were
oppressing women first of all women
aren't that easy to oppress as you might
have noticed if you've ever had a
relationship with them and you might say
well it took women a long time to
struggle forward until they attained
civil rights status that was equivalent
to men and I would say that's true but
it also was the case for men that it
took very long time to struggle forward
before there was anything approximating
individual rights and that they were
granted to women quite rapidly in the
aftermath of that and that a lot of that
was a consequence of technological
transformation
made that sort of thing even possible
but we are both privileged white males
can we really understand the suffering
of women well it depends on how how
useful you are your capacity for
understanding the suffering of others is
or how well-developed that is I don't
see that it's necessarily any more
difficult to understand the suffering of
women well I would never pose the
question that way because I don't know
how you understand the suffering of a
group being an individual I don't think
a woman can understand the suffering of
women because that makes the that's
predicated on the assumption that a
individual can take on the burden of a
group and I don't buy that assumption to
begin with I think we we vary in the
ability to let's say empathize with
others but I don't think there's any
evidence whatsoever that you can't
empathize across a gender barrier
otherwise no relationship would even be
possible a lot of people argue that
cultural oppression is still a fact in
modern society for example something
feminine is considered insulting doesn't
that sustain the oppression of women
well I think that there are negative
stereotypes associated with both forms
of gendered behavior and that if those
are utilized inappropriately they can
result in prejudicial attitudes I think
that most enterprises are imperfect
enough so that some residual prejudice
remains it might be sex it might be
preference by gender or prejudice by
gender it might be prejudice by race
might be prejudice by ethnicity or or
attractiveness or intelligence or
character there's all sorts of things
that warp the proper selectivity of
hierarchies but I think we're doing a
unbelievably good job at getting rid of
those as rapidly as is humanly possible
and that we've moved so fast in that
direction so quickly that we deserve
some credit for it there's one line in
the book where you say you don't agree
with the theory of the feminist
revolution of the 20th century but is
that the fact that the feminist movement
of the 20th century had a significant
impact for gender equality no I don't
really think so
what about semen I think you are what
would equal pay what about what happened
60s I think
that I think that to the to lay that to
attribute that primarily to the feminist
political movement is to give far more
credit to the feminist political
movement than it deserves and I think
the people who are pushing that are
primarily feminists I think that most of
what freed women was the extension of
the idea of individual rights to
everyone including women and that that
was happening not only on the on the
front of women let's say but also with
regards to people of different races and
ethnicities I think it's part of a much
broader cultural movement to extend the
idea of individual rights universally I
think that's deeply embedded in the
judeo-christian tradition and I think
that a very large number of
technological innovations played a far
more important role in the emancipation
of women than feminist political
ideology even though you can point to
certain movements like the suffragette
movement for example that pushed hard to
have the vote extended to women but even
that I would say was a manifestation of
deeper transformations at a cultural and
technological level I think the people
who are pushing the idea that it was the
feminists it was feminist political
imaginations that produced the
equalization of the situation between
men and women are mostly diehard
ideological feminists who like to think
that way but it doesn't look to me like
that's a valid historical interpretation
in the least I would like to move on now
I would like to talk about truthfulness
in Chapter eight and rule eight you
write about the law the life line mm-hmm
it's you say someone living a life lie
is attempting to manipulate reality with
perception based on what you write in
the chapter couldn't one say that a
large part of the population in 21st
century live a life life because they
avoid conflict they say what they think
pleases their spouses or their bosses
instead of telling the truth oh yes if
they do what is convenient at every
given moment instead of saying what they
really want yes well perhaps not at
every given moment but they certainly
fall prey to that temptation it's
conflict avoidance yeah well as a
psychologist psychologists deal with a
variety of problems but I would say the
two most common normal problem
our anxiety and depression that would be
one class and the other would be lack of
assertiveness and lack of assertiveness
subsumes the the problems that you just
described people won't stand up for
themselves and say what they need and
want and then they don't negotiate
properly and you might and they're
avoiding they're avoiding conflict in
the short term which is a form of lie by
omission and what that means is that
problems aggregate around them that's
often why people end up divorced you
know people will stay married for a long
time and one partner will say to the
other eventually well I've been unhappy
for the last eight years it's like well
that might have been something to
announce in increments say weekly or
even daily long before everything
accrued to the point where the only
possible solution is a catastrophic
dissolution there's a lot of conflict
involved in setting a relationship
straight you have to let each other know
who you are because you're different
that's going to cause conflict you're
going to conflict about whose job takes
priority and win you're gonna come
conflict have conflict about how to
spend your free time about how to raise
your children about how to manage the
domestic economy about what disciplinary
strategies you should use about where to
vacation about what to eat like all of
those things have to be negotiated
through and all of that requires
truthfulness so that each of you know
what the other is wants and will be
satisfied with and conflict it's very
very what would you say the only thing
more exhausting than telling the truth
and negotiating with your spouse is not
doing it and waiting for the divorce
both of them are difficult but I would
recommend the former yeah we if we talk
about the workplace what do you want to
say to those viewers that regularly you
know agree with their bosses and start
telling the truth
what are they doing to themselves in the
long run well they're taking the soul
out of their work you know let's say
well just imagine for the sake of
argument that you encounter one annoying
thing a day at work a small annoying
thing and then let's say for the sake of
argument that you could have a little
battle about that and
improve it somewhat or you could just
say it doesn't matter it's like probably
doesn't matter today oh it might not
even matter tomorrow but if you make a
thousand decisions like that which you
will do or three years then now you have
a thousand things bugging you at work
and if you wait for five years then it's
well then it's 2,000 things and the same
thing happens with your kids and the
same thing happens in your marriage
those things accrue and they turn into a
monster yep you but you would agree that
conflict avoidance is practical
sometimes people don't just go along
with no I don't actually I think in a
marriage for example there's almost
nothing so small you shouldn't fight
about it but the question is what does
fight mean it doesn't mean win like if
if you and I have a relationship let's
say it's a business partnership it
doesn't really matter if we have a
relationship and we have a difference of
opinion we need to battle it through but
the purpose of the battle isn't so that
your viewpoint prevails or that my
viewpoint prevails because either of us
might be wrong the purpose is to engage
in the conflictual exchange of opinion
so that we can see a joint path forward
to peace and that's and that's the thing
is like if you're fighting with your
wife the first thing to remember if
you're fighting with your wife is you
have to live with her
so maybe beating her in the argument is
not the right outcome what the right
outcome is is saying what you have to
say listening to what she has to say and
see if you guys can come up with a
mutually agreed upon solution that will
make the problem go away so if we
explore conversation between people in
society yeah a lot of these
conversations are full of falsehoods and
lies people are nice to people that
dislike they're being fake we can try to
be friendly yeah I mean it's is it in
fact morally wrong to live your life in
that way yes yeah it is it is I mean you
can't avoid the necessary conflict of
negotiation towards peace if you avoid
it all that it means is that it accrues
and multiplies it's the oldest one of
the oldest stories we have the oldest
stories we have point to that as
part of the prime moral doctrine you
know it's it's it's a form of
impulsivity you know if you only do what
you want in the moment impulsively that
there would be consequences of that into
the future which is why you shouldn't
act impulsively impulsively avoiding
conflict is exactly the same and people
same problem people know this you know
if if someone's casually rude to you in
in a bus driver for example and you'll
you there's always the possibility that
you'll stew for hours over what you
should have said it's like when someone
transgresses against you let's say you
have to say what you have to say you
don't have to say it as if you're the
totally correct authoritarian tyrant you
can say it in the spirit of of inquiry
inquiry you know because there's always
the possibility that you're wrong and
you want to listen this is also why you
want to listen to your partner your your
your spouse even if what they're saying
to you is you find very annoying it's
always possible that they're right and
you should listen because if they're
right then they can stop you from
heading for trouble in the future I want
to go backwards I want to talk about
rule number seven yeah pursue what is
meaningful not what this expedient you
write in the book there is no faith and
no courage and no sacrifice in doing
what is expedient what do you say to
those viewers that don't pursue their
dreams and are locked into their careers
because they are too afraid to take
risks and pursue something meaningful
well the first thing I would say is well
you should be afraid of taking risks and
pursuing something meaningful but you
should be more afraid of staying where
you are if it's making you miserable
it's like the first thing you want to do
is dispense with the idea that you get
to have any any permanent security
outside of your ability to contend and
adapt it's the same issue with children
it's like you're paying a price by
sitting there being miserable and you
might say well the devil I know is
better than the one I don't it's like
don't be so sure of that the clock is
ticking yeah and if you're miserable in
your job now and you change nothing in
five years you'll be much more
miserable and you'll be a lot older but
isn't it a luxury to pursue what is
meaningful our viewers have mortgages
they have children yeah they have
payments and loans it's a luxury to
pursue because we lack the resources
well I don't think I don't remember now
I'm not talking about what makes you
happy it's a luxury to pursue what makes
you happy it's a moral obligation to
pursue what you find meaningful and that
doesn't mean it's easy it might require
sacrifice if you need to change your job
to let's say you have family and and and
and children and Anna mortgage you have
responsibilities you've already picked
up those responsibilities you don't just
get to walk away scot-free and say well
I don't like my job I quit
that's no strategy but what you might
have to do is you think well this job is
killing my soul all right so what do I
have to do about that
well I have to look for another job well
no one wants to hire me it's like okay
maybe you need to educate yourself more
maybe you need to update your your
curriculum vitae your resume maybe you
need to overcome your fear of being
interviewed maybe you need to sharpen
your social skills like you you have to
think about these things strategically
if you're going to switch careers you
have to do it like an intelligent
responsible person that might take you a
couple of years of effort to do properly
when you say pursue something meaningful
is it important to have a vocation I
think it's more important to to have a
an ethos an ethic so I have a program
for example called the future authoring
program which is a writing program that
enables people to develop a vision for
their life and then to develop a
strategy and so it's based on the idea
imagine that and it's an extension of
the ideas in the book or at least
something along the same lines the first
thing that you want to do is figure out
imagine you were taking care of yourself
like you were someone you cared for
which is rule number two by the way
essentially then you should figure out
well if you could have what you needed
and wanted what would it be what sort of
friends would you have what would your
family relationships look like how would
you conduct yourself with your children
how would you educate yourself you need
to think through how it is that your
life could be properly arranged if you
had that ability and then you can aim at
that and
the funny thing is is that if you do
pause it a goal of that sort and work
towards it you will move towards it the
goal will change because you'll learn
things along the way but I mean I've
dealt with hundreds of people in my
clinical and consulting practice and we
set a goal we develop a vision and work
towards it and it things inevitably get
better for people so it's not a luxury
it's it's difficult it's a moral
responsibility and it isn't happiness
it's it's not the pursuit isn't for
happiness it's a moral responsibility to
pursue what is meaning absolutely I
would like to end the interview with a
with citing criticism from your friend
oh yes Bernard shift yes your friend
many years and former colleague at the
University of Toronto yes he wrote an
article about you in the Toronto Star
recently yes it was quite hard criticism
on what you've been doing in the last
few years and he wrote Norton is
fighting to maintain the status quo to
keep chaos at bay or so he believes he
is not a free speech warrior he is a
social order Warriors are you a social
order warriors I think that people can
decide that for themselves I mean one of
the things that Bernie criticized was my
lecturing style at the University now
all those lectures are online all the
essentially like a representative sample
of my lectures from the last 30 years
are online and I mean hundreds of hours
it's not a few fragments and hundreds of
thousands of people have watched them
and the criticisms that Bernie leveled
at me have not been leveled at me by the
Watchers and so people can go watch the
lectures and make up their own mind
about that but he also questions or
motives yeah he wants to know what your
end game is all about I mean what is
your primary motive my primary motive as
a clinical psychologist and educator is
to help individuals live more meaningful
and productive lives in harmony with
their families and their community
that's my motive and the evidence for
that I think is well if people go online
and first of all you can watch the
lectures and decide for yourself but you
can also go there's I suspect probably
maybe
250,000 people have commented on the
lectures and their effects on them and
so that's what people say I'm watching
the lectures yeah I'm trying to develop
a vision for my life I'm trying to
become more responsible and its really
helping and that's and that's what I
hear all the time when I do these public
lectures which aren't political but when
we gain success we raise the bar we set
our ambitions higher I mean what is your
end game what do you want that's all
that's what I want I want I want to help
as many individuals as possible become
more courageous more truthful and more
engaged in the pursuit of individual
familial and social harmony that's what
I want you're pursuing what is
meaningful
i I'm pursuing I believe that to be the
case it's certainly meaningful to me I
mean there isn't everywhere I go now
doesn't matter where I land and what's
Airport or if I walk down the street
three or four people will come up to me
and they'll tell me I was in a dark
place I was anxious depressed nihilistic
drug-addicted alcoholic homeless in jail
you name it bad relationship with my
girlfriend bad relationship with my
parents I've been watching your lectures
or reading your book I've been trying to
tell the truth to get my life together
and everything is way better and so then
you think well if you could have what
you wanted and what would be meaningful
you imagine you could go anywhere in the
world and people would come up to you
that were strangers and tell you that
that's as good as it gets
what about politics do you have
political ambitions no no political
ambitions no I I have ambitions to speak
with people who are politically
motivated if they want to speak with me
but personally I've already decided that
what I'm doing at the moment is more and
I thought this might need this choice
multiple times in my life that this
approach is more suitable for me okay
mr. Peterson thank you for your time
thank you very much for the interview